[Music]
or watch has something that a lot of
games don't have especially I competitor
game and it's just like how should I say
it's like a sense of belonging
the fans are very passionate a little
bit stable it's like you know
traditional sports fans they're like
really into it they're always like come
to the come to their team's games and
when I was younger a number of my
friends were watching soccer it looked
great they were having a lot of fun
but but like I just really wasn't
interested in sports but you know I just
still want that kind of a thing though
and I think overwatch League really
provided a lot of people with that while
it's yet to be seen whether overwatch
becomes an eSport for the masses it's
clear that meaningful steps have been
taken towards realizing that dream
overwatch league has built momentum and
with the attention paid to production
the long-term revenue potential and the
treatment of players Blizzard looks to
have laid strong foundations to build on
to conclude this series we're going to
look at what the people most involved in
the overwatch league belief of in
blizzards biggest achievements what the
league has done for eSports and their
hopes for its future
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
over watch League has created a massive
wave in media you know they you drop a
rock in the pond and the waves just keep
getting they keep spreading out well
over watch they decided to drop a
boulder in the pond and then see how
that went and so it's been drawing a
fantastic amount of attention from all
parties to the league and to eSports as
a whole and so it is a positive force in
that sense because the more eyes that
get on to eSports the more opportunities
are going to be there for everybody who
wants to look for that job in eSports
the more money that gets drawn in jobs
unlock more people are in and the more
opportunities we have to find the
creative people who are gonna continue
to push the industry forward I think
that managed to make it mainstream in a
way without pushing for it to be
mainstream I know it's been something
which eSports and the gaming community
part of them wanted it very badly
because they wanted to be a the
acceptance they wanted video game to not
be a niche thing like I don't want to be
looked at weirdly just because I like
video games that acceptance I think a
lot of people really wanted and then
there was this other side where a lot of
people didn't want it they wanted to be
that niche thing they wanted to be cool
nation on the ground
I think they somehow managed to cross
that bridge and make it okay for both
sides because it wasn't an obnoxious
pushing it to media like oh we need to
be on TV we need to do this it was
really just hey we want to make a really
cool league we want everyone to see how
amazing this game is and how fun it is
to participate to watch to cheer on your
favorite teams your your country your
town there was so much doubt and I think
a lot of people saw the news that there
were being overwatch league and
immediately your mind goes to you know
eSports event locations like the eSports
arena down in Santa Ana where it's
really well put together but it's all
very much like ok well whoever's there
this week like brings the rigs like it's
all very DIY there's a lot of fly by the
seat of your pants figure it out stuff
and this when it launched I think people
were just so blown away at the level at
way
this launched I don't think anybody was
expecting that I certainly wasn't being
in the arena is truly a singular
experience it's really fun and the first
time I walked into that arena I gasped
aloud I was like oh I mean it was
incredible it was one of the best things
I've ever seen I was like this is how I
want to watch video games all the time
even at this early stage there are signs
that Blizzard is on the right track its
belief that like traditional sports fans
those that love overwatch would relish
the opportunity to watch the game played
competitively live surrounded by fellow
fans or through online streaming
services seems to have been well-placed
Blizzard is banking on the buzz
surrounding overwatch league and the
experience of watching the game in an
arena being the fuel for its growth it's
planned to replicate the slick live
production currently only seen in the
blizzard arena in hometown stadiums is
evidence of this it's hoped that as the
passionate hardcore build attachments to
their teams the casuals will also follow
into fandom imagine Blizzcon which is
you know 20 to 30 thousand of the
world's most hardcore Blizzard fans ever
overwatch League Arena is like if you
were to take out of that 30,000 who is
the most dedicated loyal awesome fan
ever those are the people who are
showing up to that overwatch League
matches like every week and the energy
is just off the hook like it's just such
a positive embracing crowd I don't know
how to describe it the reason that we're
in Boulder Mina this year is we wanted
to give our teams time to build that
capability to learn how we do it to see
how we do it the number one key I think
to having it become more mainstream is
getting people more exposure to alive
once fans who can't make it to LA have
an opportunity to go to a home stadium I
think that's where it starts to get
really exciting and as overwatch League
grows the opportunities available to its
players will grow with it by their own
admission the athletes can
meeting today know that like many other
talent based sports their time is finite
however they feel that overwatch leak is
also giving them an opportunity for a
future in eSports beyond scoring kills
pushing payloads and securing points
this of course makes way for new players
to rise through the ranks and
interleague stardom that's something
that like I've appreciated that much
about overwatch just in such a grand
scale because as I said I was living in
Australia doing a university degree
before I moved to North America I had
nothing to my name in terms of eSports
but this is really giving me an
opportunity to build up my public
following it's opened the door of
eSports now so that I can go so many
directions from here it doesn't have to
be overwatch it doesn't have to be that
but when I do decide to start playing
there are so many avenues and I can go
and I that's one of the things I love
the most about overwatch in this
community that's been built it's a very
well organized league and the more
professional we're going to do they're
probably gonna need more manpower and I
think for players it's not really like
the last destination sure you make money
but like it doesn't mean that you have
to just like quit after you make some
money and yet when you retire if they
have the ability that can be a
commentator some people can be an
analyst coaches even managers like tons
of things actually I don't think like
some of the younger players realize that
but the second they stepped in to
overwatch League a lot of doors just
opened up for them even prior to the
overwatch League I would say that
becoming an eSports professional was
something that you could aspire to be
there were other respawns titles where
the pay would be enough or they got
salaried or something like that whatever
actually gets done differently
is not only can you just try and grind
your way to the top and do it the same
as you would in any other sports or any
other respawn just by getting noticed
and picked up by a team but overwatch
has and blizzard has very distinctly set
out a step by step process so even
though it's still incredibly competitive
and it's still very difficult to make it
to the top and and have a career in that
same sense these steps are not so murky
they're not so hidden you don't have to
really struggle to figure out okay
what's my step from here to here how do
I actually achieve it one of the things
that's really awesome about overwatch
League is that any player of overwatch
has the opportunity to make it there
some
today and we've put a lot of thought and
effort into creating a very clear path
for progression so we have first of all
open division which looks at all of
competitive play C's players of a
certain rank gives them an opportunity
to compete as part of this competitive
division and hopefully get recognized by
the tier above them which is contenders
the other thing that's very interesting
about the day and age that we live in
now with streaming being as popular as
it is if you're a really talented player
and you're streaming all the time and
you're getting recognized on your stream
well you're right out in front of
everybody who's scouting for teams or
the general manager for one of these o
WL or contenders teams it's likely that
you could get recognized that way as
well so it's kind of an exciting time to
be an overwatch player to know that
there is this path to sort of stardom
and success that's out there if you're
good enough this year I thought we laid
a great foundation to build the path to
pro for players we also want to start
thinking more about how we build a path
to pro for the millions of high school
and college kids out there who probably
want to work in eSports now but don't
actually know how to do it typically my
answer to hey I want to work in eSports
what do I do has been well you should
just start doing it you know start
writing a blog even if only your mom
reads it like it's it's a start like
start a podcast it's the barrier to
entry is so low right you can just go
start creating content you can go
volunteer at a local event there's so
many things that you can do it that is I
think a great path but further from that
as the industry starts to grow and
develop we also as League need to be
thoughtful about how we're training
talent one of the things that keeps me
up at night is how do we continue to
grow and foster and groom on-camera
talent how do we grow and foster in room
production talent if you think about an
average day at the blizzard Arena for
overwatch League there's over a hundred
people there working across the live
show all the shorter constantly produced
the event piece of that there's so many
different roles currently there's not a
super deep talent pool of people who can
step in and do those things that's one
of the things that we're gonna start
being very thoughtful about in the
future we actually have our first two
interns this summer
here at the overwatch league which we're
really excited about and bring people in
when they're young get them exposure to
what it means to work in eSports because
I think like probably know hey I want to
work in eSports but not really sure what
is actually available like what are the
things what are the different jobs that
I can do to work in eSports it's
something that we're thinking a lot
about you don't have to be an amazing
player to be involved in eSports anymore
you you can make your whole career raise
your family and just being part of the
support team of eSports there ton of
people working for cloud 9 I think we've
got some are you know we're closing on
100 employees at this point with medical
vision and dental and it seems normal to
the rest of the world in America that's
very rare regardless of whether
overwatch League fails or succeeds in
hitting the critical mass the people
responsible for creating it agree it is
a worthy endeavor for them even if
overwatch doesn't become the global
sport of the future
overwatch league will have been a stride
forward for eSports as a whole I hope
that some of the things that we've done
will inspire other game companies game
publishers eSports operators to do
similar things and to you know again
keep the whole ecosystem moving forward
because I think we're still in a phase
where eSports it isn't mass yet I think
there's a lot of people who now know
what the word is but they you know ask
me what's going on with the e gamers we
have a lot of families coming here to
the arena a lot of dads with their
daughters or mothers with their sons
whole families everyone's just coming
together into the arena seeing them
enjoying this together sharing this
passion is I can't even describe how
that makes me feel because I'm coming
from a place where that was just nothing
there was no way my parents would have
thought of enjoying video games with me
that was just that was a lot of thing so
seeing how accepted this is now it's my
me generally happy I had that one time
where dad came up with his daughter she
was the sweetest cutest thing I've ever
seen
she was super shy she smiled at me
didn't dare to actually say something so
of course I went up to her seeing that
she's staring at me so I was like hi how
are you doing and then she started
crying I was a go-go
so I went out of my knees and asked her
if she's okay and then she's like I
never thought I'll meet you I watched
with Daddy every day and I I hope I can
be like you when I grow up and hearing
that made me cry I'm almost tearing up
right now because being a role model for
a little girl I don't know words for
that I had never in my life what I've
thought that I can be this for another
person and this makes me so happy it
just makes me want to work double as
hard and do double as much so we can
inspire more people to make this career
choice to share their passion for video
games and shout it from the rooftops
I've said this before and it doesn't
make people happy when I say this but if
overwatch League ends up being a failure
which of course we hope it does not
we're doing everything in our power to
make it the most amazing thing ever but
if it ends up being a failure in my mind
it will still be a success because for a
moment it made everybody think much
bigger about what eSports not only could
be but should be
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you